face à la menace terroriste nous devons
nous unir pas seulement avec des mots
mais avec des outils avec des actions le
faire pour protéger nos valeurs pour
protéger les citoyens et pour prévenir
ces actes abominables qui que nous
constatons et nous vivons et qui
tétanise nos sociétés à voir aussi la
plus grande des fermetés à l'égard dès
terroristes car il va il en va de la
force de nos démocraties la prévention
de la radicalisation la surveillance des
réseaux qui sont utilisés de main de
maître par les terroristes pour leur
propagande morbide et notamment à
l'égard des jeunes la lutte contre le
trafic d'armes doivent être nos
priorités je me réjouis des propos de
monsieur le ministre représentant la
présidence en exercice mais il nous faut
unir nos forces en renforçant la
coordination des échanges d'informations
il faut multiplier ces échanges
d'informations il faut surtout rendre
obligatoire ces échanges
et cela en optimisant europol et en
créant un véritable pnr européen qui
deviennent cet outil efficace réforme
est aussi le 6 pour rendre obligatoire
par exemple les alertes concernant les
personnes suspectées de terrorisme et
partager ces signalements
il en va de cette politique de sécurité
commune que nos concitoyens européens
appellent de leurs voeux
merci